Mak Some Noise if you ready for teken S
Grand finals rev major 2017 was a major
Esports tournament that was part of the
Tekken World Tour no no block this
standard for let's go gold Stander his
let's go and it had one of the biggest
matches that made an impact in the
fighting game
Community Battle of the gun
this was a highly anticipated and
memorable tournament in the competitive
Tekken scene as both jdcr and KN are
participating their clashes in various
tournaments have been epic showdowns and
many believed that the two at that time
were the best Tekken players in the
world me cl it
[Applause]
out so let's take a look back at the
buildup for this legendary match that
defined Tekken
keep we got the dub step in the
background the wub wub another count
he's ready oh
that's that is a guess it is a 50/50 one
or two can't show that on screen this
match up is uhhuh um fighting any
Mishima is pretty difficult but haachi
has a lot of quick mids and the fact
that 442 is a little tricky to punish
makes it a lot harder okay down four
again he's going to need a miracle see
let's see only a real master can come
back from a a deficit like this to even
take the round okay seven golden letter
but no meter though really close to
having got him out of the there again
step for oh that's going to be it
rard oh I think that's going to be
it and knee takes it two to one over
chck I like it KN KNE just not over
exerting himself just kind of patient
willing just stand there block counter
hit on the back four that's
big after
this electric block block the low again
electric that was the correct pun bring
him up in the air doesn't even need it
finish 60 ridiculous finish that was a
blow
up the crowd going crazy and oh finally
show some love for the
crowd that's 15 look 14 seconds left to
look their life finally a big
combo 10 seconds and now j's got the
life Advantage saint has to go in N More
Than Turtle that's it he can't make this
comeback yeah tating on him you can't
beat me now no my god wow J spooky you
don't do that to your team all right
everybody we are getting started with
our top eight here the master event in
Manila Tekken World Tour top eight the
first match we're going to see today of
course go
through there's a launch at the wall not
going to get damage CU of the side
wallon oh that wild Rising one didn't
commit to the three a oh back one shut
your mouth shut your mouth girl talk to
the hand not offense his Advantage
though oh that fish hook oh back
swing and KNE cleanly takes it and
that's going to put KNE into the
Winner's finals where he's going to be
guaranteed a
oh man nice block great punish here it's
close here in this round he's going to
take it one more hit could do it all oh
I can't believe he blocked
that again look at the spacing by both
of these players oh down for one jdcr
has the life lead 19 seconds left on the
to what a side step and electric and
this should do no no no one more mixup
could do it here comes
noi oh it's in the down for one and a
nice clean this next match Steve this
next match this next one though we have
the crowd knows already the crowd knows
we have KNE versus Echo Fox's
jdcr coming up this is winner's finals
batt three out of
five Battle of the Gods this is
definitely Battle of the Gods as we
mentioned earlier there is a little bit
of tension between these players because
uh Chanel is a member of the KNE gang
Clan uhhuh and Saints is a member of the
jdcr gang Clan and those are the two
main gang Clans in the Korean Tekken SE
first to three Make some noise for these
guys it doesn't matter who you want to
win this is good ass Tekken I would buy
this as a at a store fresh Tekken jcr
I'll take two let me get two of them
this is this is good this is ready all
right jdcr picking Dragon it's not going
to be punishing it and both of these
guys represent ker right now nice ooh a
42 what a block by jdcr goes for that
one two now three tries to go for that
low again jdcr fighting back out of this
corner oh such up right now but KN of
course with the advantage here waiting
for that opportunity wow you see how he
made that
whip not on my watch he says and he dies
from the wall 19 seconds left on the
clock like I said before man when it
gets to the final second man people
start freaking out the crowd start
screaming people start bringing in
bottles I'm going start throwing things
again exactly there's no time left the
about even on life who's going to take
this it's really tough my bang way has
the life oh he went for it big shoulder
there what's going to happen oh he
didn't time match he didn't even punish
that's that's what girls do you got to
be
careful uhoh what an invasive tactic
there goes for the four two oh nice
stuff oh punish get off of me dude
oh he might be able to get a race right
here oh oh he dropped the back
throw he hit him with the oh Counter
close yo he stepped on his Jays you saw
how Fang way got mad like come on bro I
just got these and he has rage goes for
the shoulder did it again oh he has to
be careful just out of range oh do it
again oh down for one do that again oh
what a block oh block St step four is he
dead oh first game goes to KNE in a hand
in congratulatory fashion it's going to
be a long battle T so you know maybe
he's saving it for later wow what a low
parry and still gets the low Parry
that's what I like to
see oh got him trying to S step oh drops
the down
four back two down four one goes for the
down three as well you see jdc are the
back down four four he spacing is just
on another level right now down two down
four
oh oh they traded blows he goes with the
followup unable to get it the jdc
off what he's just staying away from him
he is looking for his
opportunities he is playing on another
level right now down 4 two and just as I
say that of course gets locked into the
air here's jdc's
opportunity jab the keep him standing up
goes for that up forward two oh oh a
wall Rising Three now what's he going to
do he does have
rage oh wow my email
broke oh gets the big Lun and he's going
to close it out two rounds to one get
off of me bro running low on time oh not
breaking the Thro still alive going to
have a
chance made a pizza out of him got
what's he going to do there's no time
left oh good
block there's no side oh my
God Steve I'm
speechless it's cool Co when we both
agree oh gets him with the low again and
he with a slight life Advantage here oh
wow K to get out again get off of me bro
man if this is what it's like to see
Gods go at it I don't want to do this
anymore I don't want to do this anymore
just think we haven't even had slow put
cameraman on the mic I don't want to do
it
anymore down four four oh that's that's
where that's where the Vulcan death grip
hits you that's why it hurt so bad too
this going to be do a lot of damage oh
what's he going to do oh oh oh goodness
oh no
time oh my God oh my
God oh my
goodness oh nice running too here good
pressure from JD
what a block what a but uh uh uh oh wow
he drops it and that could be a problem
Oh yeah this should be it he's going to
go into the
rard and you can see now
jdcr again both players looking for that
opening they trade blow but unable to
get a combo here oh good shoulder there
and jdcr back on the scoreboard I like
pizza can't even talk I'm telling you
this
telepathically dragonov is crazy he's
talking to his opponent like that yo you
got to remember man dragonov is you man
he can't talk oh standing for something
we haven't yet seen in the match up so
far yeah we seen him do it with devil j
a little earlier that instant while
standing twos oh he went for
it and now you see GDC there's 10
seconds left they're going to have to do
something I didn't even know that's how
much time was left on the clock God oh
he the big launch and he should be able
to steal this away he's just going to
have to run
away
okay all right Panic four again jcr
looking a lot better this time around
and you guys can see both of these guys
finding fighting those hits oh now you
see the r punishing coming from jdcr
running two again and look at this
offense another running two do it again
jdcr smell blood he's going for the kill
down four for jdcr is still alive you
see him take the headset off he is
definitely feeling a different kind of
pressure here from me well that's what
happens you start to focus on that
ground game and the neutral and the
spacing and then that's when throws
become more viable even if they're
normal throws it's funny too cuz you
know in the first match up KN did not
throw out any throw for the kill he
wants to tie it up slides in oh nice now
get the bound and the wall oh no this is
bad positioning he's going to have to
get out of there oh to follow
up oh he goes for it and I didn't know
that combo but that was tight the
reverse Kemo Step while standing for
ducks the last hit get off me dude
trying to side step there trying to
create some spacee here but now putting
him into range giving him access to the
very dangerous range Drive oh Wow breaks
the throw oh he goes for
it finishes the string and a jab to
check him on the dash in you can just
feel the tension right now dude my Jord
oh my Jord we're going to a final
match it's crazy there's a lot of moves
that we haven't yet seen from me he
hasn't wow okay using the iron pal there
he hasn't used the hot kick yet either
there are a lot of tools that we haven't
yet seen that DC might not even be
expecting needs to be careful 25 seconds
left on the clock
knee decisive lightly right now does
have the tools and the damage to kill
him in the next hit yeah J's going to
have to be very careful here uh-oh oh
Judo chop right in the side of the neck
I saw it in a he dropped it running to
you saw that Judo and get there about
even on life here who's going to take it
jdcr with a slight Advantage here oh
that's just out of range and now see a
very very rare crack from
knee this music is so sympathetic man
this is crazy it's like I know both you
guys want to win rage drrive oh block
The Hop could have got a big punish
right out of range again ex shoulder he
knew loses this we really got to throw
him off a volcano I'm sorry man that's
that look though the stakes get a lot
higher when the game looks this good
Judo chop side of the neck uh uh uh uh
oh wow miss the last oh what an evade
there from knee and uses the temple step
hop kick not even just the normal one
blocks at this time no low oh he went
for it there they're trading look
they're both in the red
oh I like
it
running oh that's the first we've seen
of it you said it before we haven't seen
many hop kicks blocks it again oh into
the big low what's he going to do he
went right under it that's it starter
trying to catch him cracking and again
doesn't fall for it here running to
again
oh nice one two into the low I feel like
he's scouting him too he is definitely
looking for us that Kimo step to try to
get out of way oh he caught him this
going to be a lot of
damage into the down to one he went for
the Hopkins and jdcr moves on the grand
finals go fox fox fox fox
jdcr
man damn what a set good set from both
of these players and man we are going to
go to the losers bracket where we
this battle is about to explode got the
orbital he might get the wall
here that's going to
be mov on in a
ridiculous oh breaking this time crazy
what he going to go for down four in
jdcr with RB major 2017 Make Some Noise
ladies and
gentlemen got to give it up for both of
these players to be outdone can I get a
round of applause for me ladies and
[Music]
gentlemen yes
[Applause]
yes thanks for watching be sure to
[Music]
subscribe
Co